er kommt zwar aus einem kleinen land
aber sein ansehen das ist riesengroß so
groß dass er gute chancen hat für
zweieinhalb jahre zum ersten präsidenten
von europa gewählt zu werden dass sobald
alle 27 mitgliedsländer den neuen eu
vertrag akzeptiert haben ich spreche von
jean claude juncker ministerpräsident
und finanzminister von luxemburg ein
mann mit einfluss der 53-jährige
christlich-soziale ist seit 1974 in der
politik und war mit knapp 28 jahren
bereits staatssekretär
juncker ist auch ein europäischer
vordenker und einer der schöpfer des
euro roger de weck befragten der
folgenden stunde jean claude juncker zu
europa und wie ein kleines land sich in
der eu durchsetzt für einmal aber nicht
im sternstunden studio sondern in der
aula der universität zürich dort war ein
anderer großer europäer vor über 50
jahren eine wichtige rede gehalten hat
willkommen hallo
dieser aller der zürcher universität im
september 1946 hälfte winston churchill
eine rede wäre jemand sein vereintes
europa imstande sich in das gemeinsame
erbe zu teilen dann genossen seine 300
oder 400 millionen einwohner glück
wohlstand und ehre der church im
chatraum ist er verwirklicht er ist zu
großen teilen verwirklicht obwohl nicht
alle glücklich sind und der wohlstand
nicht alle erreicht hat das gibt eine
nicht unerhebliche zahl europäischer
bürger die unter der armutsgrenze leben
dies entspricht mit sicherheit nicht den
tschetschenen traum aber andere träume
von churchill sind ganz in erfüllung
gegangen er hat hier in zürich von 300
millionen europäer geredet wir haben
jetzt 500 millionen europäern der
europäischen union und das knüpft an
eine andere churchill räte die ist zu
seinem großen reden haut obwohl ich die
kirsche rede nicht klein reden möchte
sei es auch nur weil er sehr engagiert
über die rolle kleiner stärken auf den
europäischen kontinent gelebt hat aber
hat in den haag 1947 aus die pan
europäische union sich zu ihrem ersten
treffen zusammen gesetzt hatte und aus
man die idee der gründung des
europarates auf den weg brachte und die
sowjetunion ihre
damaligen sogenannten satellitenstaaten
daran hinderte bei dieser europäischen
integration übungen mitzumachen und sie
im übrigen davon abhielt von den geldern
des marshall planes
zu profitieren gesagt in der nach 47 wir
fangen heute im westen am wasser eines
tages im osten zu herrn dafür und werden
genau dort sind vier gelandet wir sind
507 europäer westeuropäer mitteleuropäer
osteuropäer
georgia war groß sondern mit waldblick
seit dem beitritt viele mittel und
osteuropäer gibt es in der tat eine
mehrheit von kleinen staaten die sie
erwähnten in dieser europäischen union
und hinter rede sagte george l ich
zitiere wenn das gefüge gut und richtig
gebaut wird so wird die materielle
stärke eines einzelnen staates weniger
wichtig seien kleine nationen werden
genauso viel zählen wie große und sie
werden sich ihren rang durch ihren
beitrag für die gemeinsame sache sicher
ist das so dass die kleinen so 14 wie
die kurven
wenn ich eher im französischen fernsehen
sitzen würden wir sie sagen ja
weil wir unter uns sind wir dies sagen
meistens
weil wir ganz unter uns
würd ich sagen
wenn es die zuspitzen versuchen die
großen an einigung zu finden
und fand viele uns zu hören die nicht zu
dem großen füge ich hinzu wenn sie sich
zusammensetzen um eine lösung eine
einigung zu finden
schaffen sie es im regelfall nie und
dann es nicht die hände der vieler
kleiner hätte die mit anfassen und mit
anpacken würden dann
europa immer darauf hätte bauen können
dass die gewässer mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union oder der europäischen
gemeinschaft in früheren zeiten in eine
richtung ziehen dann werden wir viel
weiter aus für sind das wird sehr oft
gesagt und das stimmt auch in der
substanz dass die deutsch-französische
freundschaft und verzichtbar wäre und
den
europäischen zu auf den gleisen zorn das
ist so das ist aber nicht mehr
ausgeprägt so wie es früher war es
braucht immer noch die
deutsch-französische antriebskraft aber
sie reicht es braucht viele kleine die
das gaspedal mit drücken damit jedwedes
bremsmanöver das von größeren
eingeleitet würde schon im vorfeld
nicht stattfindet weil man dann weiß es
trägt den wagen aus der kurve als er
noch kandidat war dachte der
französische staatspräsident nicolas
sarkozy in ein direktorium der sieben
grossen eu mitglieder als kandidat
kammer empfiehlt denken uns gewählte
staatspräsident kann man vieles von dem
was man denkt nicht tun fühlen sie sich
als luxemburger manchmal an die wand
gedrückt
ich habe das gefühl nie gehabt
situationen
wo man
isoliert gewesen wäre das weniger
gegeben und wenn es sie gegeben habt
steuerfragen beispielsweise und dann
wird man auch sehr schnell von den
kleinen verlassen und er habe nie den
eindruck gehabt von den großen platt
gemacht zu werden überhaupt nicht was
macht man als kleines land um seine
interessen effizient da steht man
argumentiert man redet zur sache
man macht seine späße dort wo humor
weiterhilft
gemütlichen feiner ironie ohne in
berkenthin ismus abzurutschen und man
muss die dicken bretter besonders
beharrlich buchen man muss lange bohren
mit unseren kleinen bohren aus der
großen bohren müssen mit ihren etwas
größeren
worin aber sie wurden nicht tiefer
und dieses beharrliche bohren mit
kleinen bohrer ist das ein geschäft dass
luxemburg so im laufe der jahrzehnte
erlernt hat es dass seine kompetenz die
die eidgenossenschaft wenn sie denn
eines tages mit der eu wäre man halt
eher auf morgen denn auch heute also das
handwerkliche muss man lernen und man
lernt es
durch
jahrzehntelange praxis um das vererbte
vom politiker generation zu politiker
generation es wird ein zweites hobby
tools für eine art und weise da zu sein
und
erfolgsrezepte dafür gibt das eigentlich
nicht nur dieses eine vielleicht dass
man
aus europäischem geist heraus
argumentieren muss dass das stichwort
europa sehr oft aus arbeitstitel einer
einlassung ministerrat beispielsweise
auftauchen muss und gewinnen das eigenen
land ist die genaue interessen
beschreibung das eigenen land ist oder
die breite darstellung eigener
befindlichkeiten muss
in den hintergrund treten alle müssen
den eindruck haben
man strebt eine europäische einigung an
auch wenn man versucht so genannte
nationale interessen die legitimen sind
mit unter dach und fach zu bringen und
vor allem was darf niemand auf die idee
kommen dass man für weniger menschen
redet aus die vertreter größerer stadt
niemand darf jemals auf die idee kommen
dann ich rede deutlich für 400.000
luxemburgerinnen dass die sind verdacht
darf niemand haben und wie macht man das
dadurch dass man
europäische zuschnitte und europäische
profilierungen den gibt was man vor
trägt man muss aus und das ein bisschen
pathetisch zu formulieren aus
kontinentaler sicht der dinge heraus
sein argument vortragen nichts sagen -
und durch hätte gern oder luxemburg sagt
luxemburgs nein der französische
staatspräsident kann sagen lawrow ssd
und der britische premierminister kann
seinen mut und diese ergänzt das kann
man aus kleiner sohn nicht tun man kann
das tun das hat dieselbe
fortschritts behindernde wirkung aber
man muss wissen und kann das nicht so
oft tun wie die andern wir haben sie
sozusagen ein problem wenn sie es sich
stellt wie packen sie es
suchen sie sich jedes mal sozusagen nach
der
konstellation die den verbündeten die
für sie wichtig wären gehen sie
strategisch vor und suchen sie sich die
und die und die verbündeten für die und
die sachfragen muss sich irgendwann
stehen begriffene konstellationen riesch
und sie dann im positiven sinne des
wortes
instrumentalisieren einer solchen macht
man durch viele gespräche das dauert
gespräche in der europäischen union ich
rieche am telefon
und dadurch dass man sich sehr
intensiv auf dem laufenden hält über die
innenpolitische entwicklung in den
jeweiligen mitgliedstaaten das ist so
jemand am tisch sagt etwas das gefällt
oder gefällt nicht wichtig ist nicht so
sehr das erste fest zu wissen wieso er
sagt und die meisten die etwas sagen was
gefällt oder nicht gefällt tun es vor
dem hintergrund ihrer innenpolitischen
entwicklungen oder
das momentanen ambiente ist in einem
mitgliedsland man muss sie auch so auf
dem laufenden halten größere tun dass im
regelfall nicht gebrauchen dieses wissen
auch nicht wo ich auf dem laufenden
halten über das was in finnland dann
steht man muss wissen
welche färbungen die innenpolitischen
debatten in österreich haben sich kundig
machen den maltesischen und vibriert und
befindlichkeiten große brauchen das
nicht weil deren wort kommt ein
demografisch gewicht zu was kleinere
länder durch argumentative gewicht
ersetzen müssten die argumente werden
gut und reifen herr anwendung weiß dass
die anderen umtreibt
ansonsten bin ich der man wenn man an
der strategie hat sollte man sie nicht
im fernsehen erklären wann spätestens
dann haben sie verloren wer in der
eidgenossenschaft etwas bewirken will
der muss von morgen früh bis abends spät
nur an eines denken dann kompromisse in
der großen europäischen
eidgenossenschaft namens eu ist das
dasselbe das ist genau
dasselbe ich bin kein freund
sogenannter billiger oder fauler
kompromiss kompromisse schließen um eine
lösung zu finden die kanäle
das ist nicht so sehr mein ding aber
an der bildung von kompromissen
mitzuwirken die ein erkanntes problem
wirklich löst oder einer lösung sehr
nahe bringen und zwar an der lösung die
bestand hat dies ist eine
kompromisssuche die für urdemokratisch
halt und von der ich weiß dass wenn es
sie nicht gäbe wer in europa wie die
schweiz habe der eidgenossenschaft nicht
zusammenarbeiten könnten verzichten
nicht auf eigene grundüberzeugungen aber
auf
die farben die man seinen grund
überzeugen und in dem moment gerne geben
würde das muss man tun wollen das muss
man tun können dies hat aus folge dass
man da nicht im luxemburgischen
rahmen mich weiterhin bewegen darf dass
man sehr intensiv und sehr engagiert für
europäische belange in luxemburg
antreten muss ich finde stimme
diffamierte mitglieds regierung und dass
man genau so engagiert für
luxemburgische belange ohne sie
notwendigerweise immer so wenn du zu
müssen in europa eintreten nicht muss im
nationalstaat
innenpolitisch aufzuwärmen und in
brüssel das gegenteil zu tun oder in
brüssel etwas zu tun dass man zu hause
wieder in abrede stellt dies ist eine
variante das feld für uns viele
europäische regierung die zu europa
möglichkeiten geführt hat bleiben wir in
brüssel was ist dieses brüssel wie
nehmen sie dieses brüssel in
anführungszeichen war eine große
bürokratische maschine oder im gegenteil
eine hocheffiziente kleine und strafe
verwaltung in brüssel ist der geburt
auch unzählige missverständnis eines
davon ist das noch ein denn in luxemburg
in deutschland der schweiz ist das eher
sind brüste so etwas wie ein
bürokratiemonster gebe das gibt es nicht
die europäische union hat weniger
bedienstete als die stadt als mag ja
sein dass die stadt köln zu viel hat
aber die europäische union hat nicht so
viele beamte wie man denkt das hat den
den durchschnitts die durchschnitts
beamten dichter einer europäischen
großstadt wahr ist dass einige legen
brüssel arbeiten amtieren herrschenden
der walten und verwalten manchmal
vergessen für wen sie eigentlich zu
arbeiten nahmen reißbrett entwürfe zu
hauf charme der europäischen er sagte
weil sie die europäische politik von den
menschen zu entfernen droht aber
brüssel aus
im bürokratischen tausendfüßler brüssel
aus
allesfresser der in alles hineinpasst
förster noch sehr nahen grün daraufhin
europäischen landschaften so button ist
die sie da eine beschreibung die so
nicht stimmt aber so wird brüssel
wahrgenommen woher kommt das weil viele
regierungen über jahrzehnte in ihren
hauptstädten brüssel so geschildert
haben mich ärgert immer der satz
wenn man im national umfeld etwas
bewirken muss was den menschen ist so
sehr gefällt das ist die einheitliche
politik der rest ist
weniger ernst zu nehmen dann wird vieles
erklärt mit hinweis auf brüsseler
beschlüsse entscheide richtlinien und
man tut so als ob man am zustandekommen
dieser entscheidung sind nicht beteiligt
gewesen wäre die kommission
der die eigentliche chef in dieser
europäischen
behaupten star ist die kam jan ist
anscheinend die kann nur vorschläge
entscheiden tun die minister der
jeweiligen nationalen regierungen und
entscheiden tut das europäische
parlament in vielen fällen wird
einstimmig entschieden man kann da nicht
nach hause fahren und sagen wir wurden
gezwungen diese sind jenes zu tun wenn
man hat an der entscheidung
gleichberechtigt mit anderen mitteln
wird vieles wird auch
mit mehr hat und zwar mit qualifizierter
mehrheit entschieden und da wird man
manchmal über stimmt das ist aber die
regel in parramatta verfassten
demokratien zu diesem see leckten club
gehören alle europäischen staaten aber
auch wenn man eine abstimmung verliert
darf man nicht nach hause
gehen und erklären man während der
unvernunft der anderen gescheitert genau
wer wie wenn man sich in einer
bestimmten sache durch das man nicht
nach hause gehen darf und
den menschen erklärt man hatte gesiegt
diese wortwahl die sie immer wieder höre
vor allem im angelsächsischen raum
hersteller ratstagung dass
großbritannien gesiegt hatte dass
frankreich was nicht zum 16
gesiegt hat ist eine eine regens und
nach die verheerende schäden anrichten
fall der eindruck entsteht aus treffen
sich in brüssel
vertreter fast verfeinerter starten die
gegeneinander kämpfen wir nein wir
machen politik für den gesamten
kontinent wir regiert in europa nicht
gegeneinander sondern miteinander im
vertrauen darauf dass das was wir
zustande bringen
wie hieß das deutsche ziel zum wohlstand
und glück sind seit 1995 gehört sie dem
kreis der regierungs und staatschefs in
der europäischen union an wer hat man
ein bisschen zynisch wenn man die leute
kommen und gehen sieht die eben das
machen was sie soeben bemängelten
nämlich auf kosten des gemeinsamen clubs
zu profilieren
nicht alle tun dass einige tun dass
einige tun das manchmal an wir tun das
immer wieder
als ich
1995 jahren der ersten sitzung des
europäischen rates teilnahmen habe ich
mich erst mal gedruckt und nichts gesagt
das ist eine gute verhaltensregeln für
alle neuankömmlinge nicht alle
respektieren diese regeln ich stellte
fest von all denen die damals um den
tisch herum sitzen sitzt keiner mehr am
tisch das führt aber nicht darauf zurück
dass sie sich politiker oder verdammt
hat den ställen nur heiter und gelassen
fest dass ich das überlebt habe
deswegen
waren die luxemburger manche mögen
die tiefere weiß hat dieses volkes jahr
zweifel ich tue das nicht mich immer
wieder in dieses amt gewählt haben und
ich bin nicht da weil ich gepusht hatte
sondern weil ich gewählt worden bin sie
haben ja amt aufs spiel gesetzt als sie
nach dem nein der franzosen nach dem
nein der niederländer die den eu
verfassungsvertrag zur abstimmung
stellen in luxemburg und der politisches
6a damit verbanden es war nur wenige
wissen dass gegen das ab auf ein anderes
befragten in luxemburg weil wir keine
tradition in dem sinn und in dem
maßnahmen dass man dies ohne großes
problem
bewerkstelligen können das hat in
luxemburg und zwanzigsten jahrhundert
zwei referenten geben dann haben wir am
anfang des 21
ein drittes in zusammenhang mit der
ratifizierung des verfassungsvertrages
organisiert war dagegen aber die
vorherrschende meinung werden die dass
man dies tun sollte weil es keinen
zweifel daran geben dass die luxemburger
dem wie immer auch geerbten vertragswerk
zustimmen wird das war dezidiert nicht
meine einschätzung es reicht dass man
mit den menschen auf der straße werden
wir zu wissen wie viel europa
möglichkeit wie viele zweifel an europa
und wie viel europa faulheit weil es uns
im regelfall gut geht also in luxemburg
gibt aus dem franzosen niederländer nein
gesagt haben aber ich habe ja schon vor
deren nein votum zum ausdruck gebracht
ist mir klargeworden auch in vielen
gesprächen mit allen regierung schätzt
dass verlusten doch jetzt nach diesem
doppelten meiners paris unterlag auch
noch nein sagen würde dass man dann
nicht nur den europäischen
verfassungsvertrag auf der sutthauser
ablegen könnte sondern überhaupt die
idee begraben könnte die europäischen
institutionen und die europäischen
entscheidung
pianisten und die entscheidungswege
vertraglich neu zu straffen und
effizienter zu gestalten und neue
bereiche für europäisches gemeinsames
wirken
aufbrechen könnten deshalb war dieses
jahr wieder ein herzensanliegen und
viele haben das nicht verstanden in
luxemburg kamen viele sogar gemein sein
und zu müssen dies wäre ein
erpressungsversuch so ausbauen dass
erpressung wäre wenn man aus einer
niederlage hatten den vertrag im fern-
und unterschrieben die logische
schlussfolgerung
zieht nämlich von der volks souverän an
abstraft hat man das recht verwirkt
diesem volksschülerin weiterhin auf den
nerven herum zu trampeln und
der versorgung luxemburg als solches
hatte sich von einem nein auch nicht gut
erholt in europäischen
gesamtzusammenhänge dann alles unmöglich
geworden wäre weil es dann auch dieses
looks und wo ich mein das dritte meint
aus einem gründungsmitglied der
europäischen union gegeben hat und man
dann gefragt für vertrags neufassung auf
eis gelegt hat frankreich 40 von
derartigen
verfehlungen immer schnell erholen ein
kleines mitgliedsland das
mit dem makel leben muss fortschritt in
europa durch ein negativ verlaufen das
referendum verändert zu haben wir sehr
lange brauchen um wieder in den kreise
derer vorstoßen zu können die in dem
raum sitzen wo die musik gespielt wird
ich habe gerne dass luxemburg dort sitzt
wo die musik gespielt wird wenn die
schweiz das sehr wohl die musik gespielt
wird mitglied wäre der europäischen
union dann geht es nicht nur ein
referendum sondern es geht jedes jahr
über die umsetzung dieser oder jener eu
richtlinie
referenten volksinitiativen vielleicht
sogar gegen das eine oder andere was in
brüssel gemeinsam beschlossen wurde
sehen sie das als realistisch
ich gefragt ob wir sonst realistisch
ansehen dass die iv als mitglied viertel
oder ob ich es als realistisch haben sie
dass die schweiz mitglied wird unter
voller beibehaltung der besonderen form
der direkten demokratie letzteres halte
dies nicht für unmöglich halte diese
selbstverständlich für für schwierig und
man hat sich in europa und in der
schweiz eigentlich auch noch nie
intensiv und im detail mit der frage
beschäftigt wie
europäisches entscheiden und
schweizerisches nach einschalten
eigentlich miteinander in einklang
gebracht werden könnte ich gehöre zu
denen die hexen respekt vor der direkten
demokratie der schweiz habe und wer sich
etwas intensiver mit der schweiz
beschäftigt wird ja auch die
unwahrscheinliche des schweizerischen
volksfest statt die
schweizer geben manchmal per
volksinitiative der per volksbefragung
ihre zustimmung zu projekten die legte
man sie ein mittel standen europäischen
union zum referendum vor ohne zweifel
wieder einen sehr hohen prozentsatz
abgelehnt neben kam mehr erinnern dass
die schweiz einmal per volksbefragung
kann direkte demokratie die benzinsteuer
habe für das in einem mitgliedsland der
europäischen und versucht und er würde
die 90 prozent grenze sehr schnell sehr
konkret
erlebt deshalb die schweiz kann stolz
sein auf diese art der direkten volks
kontrollen der dazu führt dass erst eine
mehr als informelle mitgestaltung durch
das volk bei der politik entscheidung
auch dort kommen wurde nicht das
vorgehen
direkt gefragt wie man dies dann in
einklang bringen darüber muss man
nachdenken sich perfekt denkbar dass ich
mag das wort nicht sehr wohl dass
historisch co notiert wird dass einige
ermächtigungsgesetz
gibt wurde der schweizer volk souverän
seiner regierung und seiner band
zustimmungsrecht auf der europäischen
ebene einräumen würde ohne dass
geschossen wird zu diesen fragen noch
einmal gehört würden aber das ist
keine frage mit der wir uns aktuell
auseinandersetzen weil die
beitrittsfrage schweiz in der eu schweiz
nicht in der eu wird in der schweiz
nicht verkauft weil diskutiert und in
der europäischen union auch nicht
sagte sie diskutiert werden wird bin ein
ausgewiesener freund der schweiz ist
wäre über eine vollmitgliedschaft der
schweiz in der europäischen union sehr
froh
und wird auch perspektivisch frohlocken
weil es gebe einen schub an gesundem
menschenverstand und damit verbunden hat
am wurden heftigkeit der europäischen
union die ja manchmal gefahr läuft
abkleben schweizer gemeinsam mit amt und
würden sie daran hindern
dies zu tun tatsache ist dass die
schweiz jahren nicht mitglied der
europäischen union sein muss und von
der stabilisierenden wirkung sowohl das
eures auch von der gesamt
integration europas in hohem maße nutzen
zu tragen ich denke mir manchmal werde
ich mit schweizer freundin redet dass
der souveränität abtritt tests nicht
nicht eu nie wie die schweiz größter
sind aus die souveränität abtritt das eu
mitglied schweiz wäre der unterschied
zwischen schweiz und luxemburg ist das
fair an dem tisch sitzen wo
entscheidungen getroffen werden dass wir
mit reden mit abstimmen wenn es zu
rötungen kommt und dass die schweiz sehr
oft
abnehmer ist das und was in brüssel von
anderen entschieden würde und es
hierzulande den autonomen nachvollzug
ja es gibt aber mehr nach vollzug aus
autonomie in demselben
und könnte die schweiz
wenn sie denn eine debatte führte auf
unterstützung zählen oder würden sie
sich von vornherein heraushalten und
sagen der luxemburger mit seiner
erfahrung obwohl sein land in mancher
hinsicht durchaus vergleichbare
interessen hat musste ich von vornherein
zurückhaltend also ich habe mir
luxemburgisch
luxemburgisches sich wohlfühlen auf
unserem kontinent überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dann luxemburg nicht der
europäischen union wäre und dies hat mit
sehr unterschiedlichen historischen
erfahrungen zu tun
zweiter welt geht in luxemburg ein
zweiter werk in der schweiz in völlig
auseinander driften erfahren dass setzt
sich über generationen
hinweg es gibt keine schweizer groß
väter die ihren hängt und
kriegserlebnisse schildern müssen die
gibt es in luxemburg wie das in
frankreich gibt es in deutschland das
hat also sehr verschiedenartige
prägungen im volk charakter werde ich
das so sagen darf
zuvor gehabt aber wenn die schweiz
mitglied werden möchte würde ich das
selbstverständlich
ja auch mit herzenslust mit herzens
laune unterstützt hat allerdings
überhaupt nichts davon aus nicht falls
er in die schweiz zu reisen und den
schweizern zu erklären wie sie am besten
sich selbst zu ihrem endgültigen
kontinentalen glück verhelfen könnten
einander belehrungen von außen verbieten
sich die vsf versteht etwas von kleinen
räumen zum kleinen völker luxemburg
seine räume und kleine völker sind nicht
der raum in dem appell von außen und
einwirkungen von außen besonders
willkommen die historische erfahrung von
luxemburg ist das zerrieben werden in
den europäischen kriegen die historische
erfahrung im kriegerischen zwanzigsten
jahrhundert der schweiz war abseits
stehen lohnt sich würden sie sagen dass
es sich weiterhin lohnen könnte der
absatz stehen lohnt sich nicht alle
abseits steht dann aber alle abseits
stehen dann lohnt sich das abseitsstehen
für nehmen dann wird das spiel für den
gesamten kontinent sofort abgepfiffen
ich kritisiere die schweiz nicht für die
tatsache die glückliche fügung auf den
schwarzen raum bezogen dass sie nicht in
die kriegswirren das von sich und uns
hinein gezerrt wurde wie andere das
würden aber luxemburg
liegt zwischen frankreich und
deutschland zwischen diesen sich über
jahrhunderte
mit feindlichen blick und gebärden
gegenüberstehenden europäischen
großmächten das fernsehen die monster
sind sie heute nicht mehr es hat in den
letzten 400 jahren alle 15 jahre krieg
zwischen deutschland und frankreich
gegeben und luxemburg sagt immer
kriegsschauplatz ich habe das schon
erwähnt öfters in der schweiz mein vater
wurde gegen den willen und gegen den
willen eines ganzen volkes
unter der deutschen besatzung im zweiten
weltkrieg gezwungen also der wehrmacht
zu werden nicht weil er das foto nicht
weil er lust verspürt hatte
das deutschtum in fremde räume hinein zu
tragen sondern weil er gezwungen wurde
und fall dieses kleine luxemburg ähnlich
wie das elsass wo dies auch stattfand
sich dagegen nicht wehren konnte wenn
ich vor den herausforderungen
auch neuerer geschichte stehe und um die
beschränktheit luxemburgischer arsenal
und mittel war es bis hin zu
diplomatischen mitteln dann komme ich
sowohl auf rationalen erwägungen auf
rationale erwägungsgrund lag als auch
damit wäre nicht nur mein herz sprechen
lassen so keine anderen
schlussfolgerungen aus dass es für
dieses kleine großherzogtum keine andere
wahl geben kann als
mitmachen
über luxemburg wurden früher entschied
luxemburg an schaltet jetzt mit wenn es
um sein oder nichtsein luxemburgs ging
haben die großen mächte und die fremden
entschieden ohne dass jemand auch nur
mit uns geredet hat wie als mit
luxemburg jetzt weitergeht jetzt sitzen
wir
gleichberechtigt an den tisch für die
kontinentalen linien jeden tag neu
gezogen werden das ist als
unwahrscheinlicher souveränitäts gewinn
für ein kleines land
anderes beispiel euro luxemburg hat seit
1921 eine währungsgemeinschaft mit
berlin gehabt mit wenig rechten und mit
wenig
steuerungsmöglichkeiten jetzt sind für
der gleichberechtigt miteigentümer der
stärksten währung der welt europa hat
luxemburg die möglichkeit geboten den
beschränkungen die durch geografie und
demographie anstehen
zu entziehen sie die schweizerinnen und
schweizer zu den rosinen picken
ich mag ja die art und weise nicht wie
in der eu untersuchung manchmal über die
schweiz gerettet wird schweizerische
strukturen sind gewachsen aus gutem
grunde die föderative ordnung der
schweiz hat weit
weit zurückliegende
historische gründe
und ich erlebe die schweiz auch nicht
als rosinenpicker schweiz und luxemburg
werden ja vor allem in sachen
finanzplatz und bankgeheimnis sehr oft
in der rubrik derer kategorisiert die
rosinenpickerei hermachen wird dabei
respektieren wir international affairs
regeln und normen geben in demselben
umfang dann nicht sogar besser als
manche die mit dem moralischen
zeigefinger dauernd auf die folgen
luxemburg betreiben
ich habe mein leben
kompliziertes verhältnis
zur schweiz ist praktisch so einfach ist
das und wenn sie sie mögen dann
vermissen sie nicht die haltung
diese bemängeln sie nicht die haltung
dieses landes die sagt ich mag sie
mehrere mein nationales interesse und
bringe das was ich in europa einbringen
könnte nicht ein das ist nicht falsch
ich entscheide ich halte sie für falsch
weil ich eben nicht glaube auf mittlere
sicht dass man
die gewinnmaximierung
quasi aus sterzing geologie in die
nächsten jahrzehnte
tragen können aber ich wäre nicht falsch
nicht über den irrweg und von dem ich
denke
dass sie sich auch befinden weil diese
sich nicht
wenn diese sich verbietet die schweiz
muss selbst für sich entscheiden ob sie
mitglied der europäischen union werden
möchte oder oder nicht und sich die
frage stellt ob das auf dauer gut gehen
kann das werden die europäische union
sich nachdem sich jetzt nach mittel und
westeuropa ausgedehnt hat weitere räume
eigentlich
zu europäischen eu räumen werden lässt
ob sie dann diese stand alone prezi
dieses ich allein das ja kein ich gegen
den rest der welt bin ob sie dass sie
sich das noch leisten kann richter die
entscheidungen die in der europäischen
union getroffen werden werden umso
schwieriger wird das
schweizer sonderweg in diesem
europäische
regeln und normen werke
ausfindig zu machen das wird die schweiz
auf dauer nicht leisten können aber es
ist nicht meine sache die anderen
europäer und für luxemburger schaut eh
nicht sagen den schweizer nicht
händeringend dass sie mitglied
mitglieder in der europäischen union
werden müssen also keine zugriff und
keine entwürfe von außen aber im
gespräch mit man schwarz rechnet
freundin davon habe ich viele plädiere
ich immer für
diese dosis gesunden menschenverstand
den es braucht um die zusammenwachsen
dinge richtig einzug viele schweizer
vertreten so etwas wie eine
exit-strategie die schweiz die sich viel
stärker auch zb nach asien wo das
wachstum jetzt ausgebrochen ist
ausrichten müsste nach den vereinigten
staaten und europa etwas weniger
gewichten sollte dieses angeblich etwas
erlangte europa also dass
die schweiz sich
interessiert an dem was außerhalb
europas im wachsen werden begriffen ist
halt wie für einen völlig normalen
reflex dies tut die europäische union ja
auch wir verfügen über asset strategien
über afrika strategie wie russland
strategie und die schweiz
profitiert zwischen gänsefüßchen ja in
hohem maße von der ruhe und stabilität
die die europäischen nun in diese neu
erstellten wirtschaftsräume hineinbringt
genauso wie sie von der stabilität auf
den europäischen kontinent profitiert in
den euro der euro unseren
wirtschaftsräumen gebracht hat was wäre
dann mit aus dem schweizer franken
gewürgt und die bürger aus allen
europäischen werden dann es den euro
nicht gebe angesichts der aktuellen
turbulenzen auf den film auf den
finanzmärkten das wären dann passiert
mit dem schweizer franken und den
anderen europäischen währungen am 11
september 2001 oder anlässlich des
irakkriegs werden wir ein riesiges
währungs durcheinander in europa in
früheren europäischen währungssystem
gehabt mit einer massiven abwertung der
südeuropäischen währungen beispiele
lehrer mit einer relativ substanziellen
aufwertung sogenannter soliderer wärmen
im norden europas die schweiz freut oder
den euro ärmer und die europäer bringen
auch die schweiz
profitiert und die kritisieren ist dafür
ein dass er sagen aber trittbrettfahrer
ich sage was nicht ist seine nur
objektiv betrachtet ist die eurozone ein
stabilitäts liefere auch für die fleißig
beklage dass nicht für das beklagen wenn
es nicht so wäre ich hätte nur gerne
dass man dies auch sieht dass der euro
nicht nur in seinem eigenen
währungsgebiet stabilisierende wirkung
entfaltet sondern auch um dieses gebiet
herum stabilisiert die wirkung des
hauses aber
entschieden wird in frankfurt nicht in
zürich wenn die eu maßnahmen trifft die
möglicherweise schweizer interessen
tangieren dann ist sehr schnell in
diesem lande das gefühl eines
imperialismus von seiten der
europäischen union sei es dass es stau
gibt es an der grenze bevor das schenken
regime sozusagen
begann einzutreten sei es dass man
report soll er machen wollte oder sei es
jetzt im sogenannten steuerstreit wo die
eu forderungen an das schweizerische
steuersystem erhebt gibt es einen willen
die schweiz zu knechten sie jedenfalls
zu beherrschen es gibt den
unverkennbaren willen einige angst
machen der schweiz diese debatte so
darzustellen aber es gibt in der
europäischen union diesen willen nicht
das gibt im gegenteil in der
europäischen union eine vielzahl waren
nicht alle
unsere mitglieder die zu der schweiz
freundschaftlich gefärbt
beziehungen und da möchten die schweiz
ist wird ja nicht von den europäern
betrachtet als ein eindringling in
feindliches gebiet wir sind
mit dem schweizer zusammen
europäer und die tatsache dass die
schweiz nicht mitglied der europäischen
union ist nimmt er ja das europäische
signum nicht
weg und im übrigen
einige kollegen ist selbst auch haben
sehr oft schweizerische standpunkt in
den brüsseler verhandlungen auch in den
brüsseler verhandlungen mit der schweiz
vertreten die regelung die wir in sachen
regelung der
zinsbesteuerung erreicht habe wie in
europa haben wir in sehr engstem kontakt
mit den französischen freunden kollegen
in brüssel
durch furten manchmal war luxemburg
sogar froh darüber dass das die schweiz
gab und sehr oft wirken die schweiz froh
darüber dass er flugs im programm
verharmlost ich gab aber wir kommen und
am tisch nur die europäische
entscheidung fiel mit verhandeln und
dann erst würde mit der schweiz entfernt
und das wäre mir lieber gewesen die
schweiz wäre mit am tisch gewesen aber
die fragen hatten überhaupt wird ist die
kommission sowie sie agiert in aktuellen
steuerstreit mit der schweiz gut beraten
und
plädiere bestand dafür dass
es zu direkten verhandlungen mit der
schweiz auf der politischen ebene kommen
verhandlung schon die die schweiz gehört
ja nicht akzeptieren das finde ich ja
eigentlich
an fehlt leben die semantische
politische rhetorik kiste dass man in
der schweiz was im übrigen kann das
steuerrecht erkenntnis nimmt einen
feinen unterschied zwischen gesprächen
und verhandlungen
macht ich weiß gar nicht für alle
sprechen völlig bereiche bin ich bald
der grenze zum eintritt in den
verhandlungsraum eingetreten ich würde
dieses
ist ingo da nicht lange aufrechterhalten
das ist im interesse der europäischen
union mit der schweiz verhandelbare
und belastbare ergebnisse zu erzielen
das ist im interesse der schweiz
indirekte ferne aber auf höchster
politischer ebene mit den kommissaren
mit dem kommissionspräsidenten
einzutreten anstatt diese probleme sich
auf
einem tisch anhäufen zu lassen umgehen
herum
hohe beamte der kommission sitzen geht
also um politik hier geht erst um den
anständigen umgang mit einem souveränen
start und das ist die schweiz und das
kann man nicht fair beamten im
schlechten sinne des wortes das muss man
auf gleicher augenhöhe verhandeln können
also hier ihre kritik an brüssel auch
das
mach ich dann sage ich die kritik auch
in brüssel vorgetragen und das habe ich
getan und das war die reaktion
die kennen sie aber wir kommen auf
dieses thema zu man auch die deutschen
auch die österreicher andere tanja die
auffassung dass wir unser auskommen mit
der schweiz haben ist und diese
verhandlungen werden geführt werden
wobei ich war zwischen freund gerne
darauf aufmerksam machen würde dass sie
weniger aufgeregt haben diese
verhandlungen herangehen sollten es wird
auch in der übrigen schweiz zwischen
presse mit einer inbrunst über diese
steuer verhandlungen oder gespräche
diskutiert und diskutiert die in keiner
weise
in der europäischen union anzutreffen
ist über die schweiz wird am tisch der
minister nicht geredet auch nicht über
den sogenannten der streit mit der
schweiz deshalb uns auf der politischen
ebene noch überhaupt nicht in vollem
umfang erreicht und ich finde die wir
von der schweiz dass er etwas ruhiger
etwas souveräner
mit diesem mit diesem thema umgehen
würde es besteht keine
feuergefahr es gab eine zeit da in der
eu wie in der schweiz der europäische
gedanke beliebte war als heute und da
haben wir ein paradox auf der einen
seite große erfolge die europäische
wiedervereinigung ist in geordneten
bahnen gelenkt worden und vollzogen
worden der euro ist da der europäische
binnenmarkt ist
historisch erfolg auf der einen seite
und unter den europäerinnen und
europäern eine zunehmende distanzierung
vom gedanken wie erklären sie diesen
widerspruch
ich mag ihn nicht ich leite manchmal
auch an ihm weil
diese lama ist diese einheitlichkeit
viele europäer eigentlich nicht passt
dass wir uns an unseren erfolgen nicht
freuen und auch nicht tun wollen nur
misserfolge zu
verhindern weil
misserfolge in europa verhindern wurden
setzt voraus dass man der europa haben
ist das problem dass das in der
europäischen öffentlichen meinung sofern
es die gibt es nicht wirklich dass zwei
gründen tendenzen gibt 50 prozent der
europäischen menschen wünschen sich mehr
europa und 54 prozent der menschen in
europa sind der auffassung dass wir
schon europa zu viel hat und diese
beiden
befindlichkeiten grund befindlichkeiten
die ausübenden jedem europäischen land
gibt die können miteinander kaum ins
gespräch kommen und der politik gelingen
das auch nicht eine brücke zu schlagen
zwischen denen die gerne mehr euro
button denen den europa heute schon zu
zeiten reichen früher war alles
einfacher so reden ja alle die die
vor guten politischen autors befindet
bis 29 gegen sehen die politiker das war
zu früh
viele
wissen dass die europabegeisterung
früher größer wenn man wollte europa
machen weil der wunsch europa weiter zu
bringen zu vertiefen eher der wunsch
einer acht geprüften generation wird der
der kriegsgeneration wer sie unsere
väter
krieg erlebt hat er im krieg verwundet
wurde wer seine texte und dafür und
städte nach kriegsende wieder von
hardware wiederaufbau im nationalen
rahmen hat machen müssen wer bescheiden
sein musste damit seinen kindern besser
leben konnte hat zu dem was das
europäische an sich bedeutet eine völlig
anderen bezug auf unsere generation dies
dies haben uns hat die sonne dauernd auf
den kopf gebrannt manchen erkennbar zu
viel und den vorgänger generationen
mache
das leben eigentlich in jungen jahren
schon entgegengetreten er mit einer
schrecklichen fratz aus mit einem
freundlich lächelnden gesicht und diese
männer und frauen die eigentlichen
erfolgstrainer der europäischen
integration haben mit aller gewalt aber
mit einer friedlichen gewollt den
zusammenschluss des kontinentes
gewohnten vier sind erben der leistung
der
vorgänger-generation und erben zieht nun
den satz und fern so tüchtig wie die von
denen sie geerbt haben das klingt
fatalistisch sollte ich beschreibe etwas
was ich sehe und eine sorge die ich habe
und die sorge ist die wenn wir die
europäischen dingen nicht festmachen
wenn wir jetzt das europäische was er
nicht
einfließen lassen aus denen dieses
wasser nicht übertreten kann dann wird
dies nicht mehr gelingen vieles vorher
reichlich hatte gerne und der euro war
ein stück auf dem weg dass die
europäische einigung irreversibel wird
weil dieses ewige thema dieses
dramatische europäische thema sich
zwischen krieg und frieden immer wieder
erscheinen zu müssen ist kein thema das
aus der vergangenheit stammt dies ist
ein thema das hoch aktuell werden kann
wenn wir nicht auf diesen europäischen
kontinent
höllisch aufpasst nun die die unsere
länder regieren werden in 30 jahre oder
die unsere gesellschaften animieren
werden in 30 jahren die null ahnung
haben von
den
zwängen die unsere vorgänger generation
dazu gebracht hat den europäischen
kontinent in frieden zusammen was uns
lassen die werden die kraft nicht haben
nun dies zu tun weil sie auch ja weil
ihnen das sentimentale und damit auch
das moralische argumente fehlen für cs
jedenfalls nicht glaubhaft für alle
verständlich darstellen können deshalb
wir sind erben der kriegsgeneration aber
wir sind die letzten die dieses erbe
wirklich auf dem europäischen kontinent
glücklich verankern können und das sage
ich nicht weil ich lust habe zu
generationen zu beschimpfen oder war
nichts zu kunst unglaublich wäre dass
mir mein gefühl wenn sie am tisch des
europäischen rats sitzen dann sind sie
einer der wenigen die noch
leidenschaftlich europäisch denken
ja ich
mache
in folgende beobachtung
seine
kollegen in den kreis der
regierungschefs zu stoßen ich werde
jetzt mal von dem westeuropäischen
kollegen im
zentrum in dem osten europas ist das
noch ein bisschen damit dass diejenigen
die europa im bauch haben und die das
europäische dass sie im bauch tragen
langsam
rationalisieren und dann auch
artikulieren es gibt diejenigen davon
gibt das wäre für die ist europa
eine selbstverständliche sache
und für die ist europa wirtschaft und
handel und euro und und und und dann
stelle ich fest
bei gf schritt habe ich das bald
feststellen dass das ohne den tropf zu
verlassen langsam in den bauch rutscht
dass das auch wirklich ein aus dem bauch
heraus erlebtes europa wird das dann zur
richtige europäische leidenschaft führt
wie bei schritte vom fehler nicht
bemerkt aber trotzdem geschrieben so
verbinden sich
das rational erdachte und
im täglichen kleinen klein
weiterentwickelt europa mit
der landschaft derer die das im bauch
tragen es trotzdem auch im kopf haben
ich habe das
im bauch da spüre ich es und ich habe
das im kopf da lasse ich aus reden viele
möchten aber am liebsten sich begnügen
mit so etwas wie einer europäischen
freihandelszone
dies immer für ein falsches konzept und
verdächtige eine die immer in richtung
erweiterung der europäischen union in
weitere räume hinein bis in den kaukasus
zidane plädieren dass sie dies
eigentlich wollen europa ausgehobene
freiheit ist und ich halte das konzept
der frei haben es schon auch der gruppen
freie zone für ein zusatzkonzert werden
im land kompliziert geblieben
kommt man kann durch macht logik
indische macht organisation vieles
bewirken dann diese macht geschehen wenn
dieses macht geschehen nicht
unterfüttert wird ja ich versuche mal
ein automatisches
hier in unserer gespräche mit liebe zu
andern die sonst vorleben so
intensiv nicht kenne dann wirkt dieser
machten sich selbst
zusammenbrechen man muss dafür sorgen
und deshalb ist die freihandelszone an
ein ungenügendes konzept das die
menschen die in diesem wirtschaftsraum
leben gerne in diesem wirtschaftsraum
leben das sie auch dass die
sprachenvielfalt mögen dass sie die
landschaft gestern zu in europa gibt
mögen dass
sie durch das kennenlernen der
kulturellen vielfalt und des kulturellen
reichtums der anderen selbstsicher
bereichen es braucht den nationalstaat
die sofortige nähe das sind dass man
kann das darf man den menschen auch
nicht denn ich bin gegen das konzept der
vorstand von europa ich bin
für ein europa wo man
in zwei richtungen tittmann hat die
nationale dimension das probiotikum hat
die die europäische dimension dass
patriotismus aber nationen sind auf
dauer ist sind keine provisorischen
erfindungen der geschichte und man
sollte auch nicht den eindruck als ob
die europäische union nationen und
regionen
lokales und regionales
verdrängen aber gerade diejenigen die
die freihandelszone möchten denken dass
das die beste methode sei um die nation
aufrechtzuerhalten in ihrer vollmacht
ich glaube nicht dass die nation an die
ich glaube ohne das zu überhöhen ich bin
nicht immer der das national überhöht in
japan lag und zwar sehr aber
es
gibt kein gramm cannstatt keine nation
in europa die aus sich selbst heraus
den anforderungen der zukunft
gewachsen denn europa ist mit einem
sammelsurium von aber
ein kraftvoller kleinstädten ich sage
dies aus zwei kleinste staat wenn der
europäischen union ahnt man darf nicht
denken wir hören das nicht gerne sagt
dass trotzdem dass deutsche und
franzosen bei einer tätigkeit die beiden
völker in sich drin bei einer
wirtschaftskraft die folgen durch und
hat in der welt den respekt genießen
denn sie genießen wenn sie nicht
mitglieder der europäischen union
wären
sagen die nicht oft wissen die aber sehr
genau
mit anderen worten hat churchill fast in
einer ironie der geschichte in dieser
rolle eine rede gehalten als ein brite
der letztlich sich als außenstehender
betrachtete und die vereinigten staaten
von europa der aus riesch oder die art
vereinigte staaten von europa da sollte
großbritannien nicht dabei sein in einem
lande die schweiz die ebenfalls nicht
dabei sein will also
beeindruckend an der church in rhede er
in zürich sind viele satz und dauerhafte
aufmerksamkeit erheischen der satz
in dem er sagt das was er jetzt hier
vorgetragen hat in diesem saal betreffe
nicht das vereinigte königreich
da hat er sich erklärt war
großbritannien ist er mitglied der
europäischen union geworden manchmal
schwierig ist mitglied aber ich finde
ein unverzichtbares mit so und jetzt hat
er dann die rede vielleicht dann auch am
falschen ort möchte man meinen weil er
gesagt hat europa europäische einigung
passiert ohne das alte königreich hat
dass sie in zürich hat das verhalten
königreich ist hier dabei in vielen
jahren wahrscheinlich jahrzehnten dann
wieder ein
gespräch zwischen zwei europäer in
diesem saal stattfindet
wird man vielleicht sagen und er hat
sich zwei mal geehrt er hat gedacht
großbritannien würden die mitglied
werden und er hat gedacht ich sage da
sind ja schweiz völlig frei die mitglied
werden möchte vielleicht stellt sich die
santander weniger irrtümer der sehr
beeindruckenden georgia biografie heraus
jean claude juncker ich danke für dieses
gespräch
danke
dieses gespräch können sie auch als dvd
oder vhs kopie bestellen unsere adresse
wie immer schweizer fernsehen redaktion
sternstunden 80 52 zürich oder per e
mail an stern kobinet sf.tv